hi I'm levar burton and we all love to
be read to especially children but I
believe adults need to be read to and
Millennials especially because their
lives are so stressful today's selection
is the abc's of 2017 written by Tracy
Clayton and heaven Nagato
a is for alternative facts what adults
now call lies B is for Beyonce and the
apples of C is for contouring YouTube's
big obsession D is for debt which a lot
of folks are left in e is for emoji our
modern Romance language f is for fidget
spinner because even our kids are
anxious G is for jiff and yes that's
really how you say it H is for our
heroes who continue to slay it I is for
impeachment on everybody's minds J is
for the juice who's loose another time k
is for the KKK who feels safe to come
out of hiding L is for love is love is
love to counter the hatred and fighting
M is for Millennials who just can't do
anything right in is for know a word
that helps us fight the good fight oh
it's for the oh crap what we say when we
hear the news P is for Putin one of
trumps most trusted Moos Q is for
questions which we'll ask until we croak
r is for reading which is how we stay
woke S is for sorry not sorry the cry of
the unapologetic T is for the trash this
world becomes if we continue to let it U
is for universal health care which we
shouldn't have to move to Canada for V
is for voting rights you'd think we were
in 1964 W is for the wonder women who
punch
Basso and kick X is for our ex-boyfriend
Obama on Instagram making us sick
why is for you still getting up every
day and doing it again tomorrow and z is
for the zoo this world has become please
come back
Obama damn this is depressing
[Music]